we fixed a truck and I thought that the
name of the episode we actually fixed a
truck we are awesome and I normally suck
it onto mechanics I know but you know
this was only this big it might have
been a hot wheel just the you know tire
fell off and fully put back in it's just
like BAM and we just happened to see a
sample so called we fixed the truck I'll
train you right okay starts off in finds
a truck fittingly enough uh and pushes
it home and they want to fix it but they
don't know how but then banana man comes
in from that the one episode where Jay
thinks he's gonna die right yeah and he
says that he knows how to fix it so they
put it together and they pimp it out and
sort of make it their own thing and they
just start driving around and then like
I said I want to get banana man a
girlfriend and these ceases guard that
he really likes so they you know serve
drive him by and just say he's cool
drive off but then bubblegum is being
chased by an angry mob because they
think she's some sort of lizard monster
which of course is ridiculous but then
BMO says eat this bug and she does it
turns out she is a lizard monster and
then they throw the car into the lizard
monster and blow up the lizard monster
and then the real bubblegum comes up and
says there's a lizard monster but they
said it's okay we took care of it and
then the guy comes up and tells banana
man that you're coming with me but not
for anything good it's because you're
naked cuz they had to use is close to
stop the lizard monster and they take
away but it's okay cuz she's pinching
his bunch so I guess there are couple
now and then they see that the hot rod
is destroyed and they just give a thumbs
up and that's the episode I really like
this one it's totally random there's I
mean like everything that's introduced
does make it you know until the end but
I mean there's not there's not a whole
bunch of a flowing narrative through it
I mean it's like you serve it's just
here's a bunch of here's the setup and
here's a bunch of random stuff that
happens around that setup um but it was
all really funny there's there's this
one scene I love where BMO changes her
batteries
she puts the batteries down gets in
front of it takes her batteries out so
she goes off and then falls onto the
batteries are just brilliant love that
uh the the sake or the the build up I
should say into bubblegum beam does
lizard monster cuz it starts off as a
radio call right at amides in like I
think she's been taking over and it's it
sort of sounds like you know what's the
word that's not propaganda but like you
know seriously theory
yeah Theory Theory radio and stuff and
so posted by a study the gravedigger
yeah so it's great seeing that lead into
the angry mob chasing her because you
know exactly why and then they throw in
another twist is that she really was
taken over by this lizard monster which
is both of those just made me laugh
really really hard and then okay here's
the strangest thing like one of the
things that made me laugh really
strangely hard it just really cracked me
up a weird al' I know does the voice for
the banana man and they left in any time
he clears his throat that just kills me
cuz you never hear that in anything
animated there's no point in animating
in somebody clearing their throat but he
does at least twice in this yeah and
it's totally pointless but it's it's you
just never see it and I just kept
telling myself they had to actually
whatever animate maybe you know ten or
twelve frames of him going up clearing
his throat and putting his arm down I'm
just like they took effort to animate
him clearing his throat and that is just
hilarious um so yeah it's just it's
total nonsense its total silly but they
get kinda like the last one it's with
characters you liked I like you know I
like hearing rales voice I like hearing
him sing that little song I like just
seeing BMO listen to radio while doing
drawings instead I just like watching
these characters I like that there was
no definite like beginning middle and
end or at least it wasn't a very flowing
beginning middle and end it you had no
idea what direction it was gotta go and
I love the way the truck looks honestly
I love I don't know it maybe it's just
I'm not a car person at all but there's
still something cool about just seeing
people put together you know doing auto
mechanics in like their way like you
know the adventuretime way where they
can just put like a horn in front or
something like that you know or the fins
in the bag I just I don't know I just
really really liked it even though it's
complete really completely random and
most likely an entirely pointless you
eat this bug I don't know I like it but
hey I don't know why I like it like
everything like I yeah I'm with you I'm
not a car person at all like our town
has like the every weekend they have
this Auto Show oh you must really stops
traffic they close everything off pretty
much and it's annoying and I'll try find
our a walk-by it'll be like oh yay look
a car another one that we've seen every
frickin weekend stop I understand people
left passions and I have my own bizarre
ones where people would look at me and
think the exact same thing so I'm not
telling anyone to never do that or not
to do that but to me it's just it's lost
on me so when they're talking about
fixing a truck I'm just like I'd rather
be doing a whole lot of other things
other than fixing a truck but I love the
reason why banana man is doing it he's
so excited especially when he wakes up
was a good thanks to know we bread yet
poor banana man I just feel bad for him
he's so lonely and he's I well the other
thing too I mean I got a huge car prison
either but even when he's like
explaining how the engine works and what
the top is for kind of like really
alright like am i doing learning
something here cuz I clearly know
nothing about cars yeah that was a great
it's like how does that thing exist then
if it's in the show IV it's just that
grass or whatever so yeah what I thought
they had a minute
like a teacher almost like even with the
whole clearing of the throat because
teachers clear their throat I think
that's kind of what they were going for
it I think they nailed it
Kobe you know that's that's a very good
point yeah I especially because teachers
have to talk so much and stuff yeah
there's something you know a lot of
people always say and lolis the right
you know the stories said to have a
three-act structure beginning middle and
end and it has to flow and it has to be
a flowing narrative I have to be feel
very natural and stuff uh but I think
there's something to be said when people
can take that and really play with it
can't break it apart um you know I like
shows like Louie that clearly sometimes
I'll have a beginning middle and end and
hard times they'll just like whatever
happens in the opening could have
nothing to do with the next two scenes
and maybe the two scenes are connected
and that it's you never know where it's
going to go but that's part of the fun
you have no idea what's coming next
yes Louie the cartoon no the CS Lewis
you've seen the show it's so good um you
can watch it I'm like let's check it
what did some where I'm like but it's
it's really really good but the but part
of the show is that it's literally just
watching his life you know it's strange
things are still in it strange things
that obviously can happen in reality you
know but it's it's just watching go
through a day or a week or something
it's like it's like a real show about
nothing you're just watching this guy
and it's like if you're to be asked what
was that episode about it's like you
couldn't say some of you could but like
you really couldn't say like there's
there's an episode where he's on a plane
he's talking to a guy and then the
planes about to crash and everything's
shaking and there's him in the air and
they're screaming they're yelling
they're all doing
ah and he just cuts him walking out the
plane we'll see you later yeah okay you
have no idea what happened you have no
idea what happened to that plane or what
saved or anything and it's just so
strange and so random like that and in
that humor like that kind reminds me of
something like this where it just it's
something can come out of nowhere it can
be totally random but it's still
enjoyable and fun to watch you know and
I like something that can really play
around with that comment I thought it
fit the narrative structure very well
begin with the car
- didn't work middle they fixed the car
finally works and car is dead it's a
it's a birth cycle it's the cycle of
life
wait Simba holding up was a team owned
as a brother yes yes Timon no no you
hold up the truck
you know like Simba the hot wheel yes
there's a narrative right there with the
lizard in there the needs bugs and and
and conspiracy radio and beemo drawing
and yeah all that happens in normal life
sure
do you haven't seen a regular day in his
life stuff like this happens all the
time it's um it's a bit creepy but it's
always fun
I liked it especially BMO yeah eat this
bug
I like BMO just gets more and more
likable silence Oh phone - enough brain
will you unplug it please cuz I don't
care who's calling everyone sucks my
only problem is is they showed cinnamon
bun you just didn't like that you saw a
cinnamon bun
well because you're supposed to be in
the back oh god it is unplugged it's
kind of creepy no cinnamon bun isn't
there anymore remember
we're cinnamon oh that's right he's it
the the flame Queen now right by the
flame princess yeah yeah but she's Queen
now right doesn't she yeah but she's
still princess hey yeah hey cuz it's
like no this kingdom just doesn't have
Queen nobody else except lumpy Space
Princess she had a queen I think like
did she appearance we know they're one I
was gonna say we only know if they work
in your queen so no look I saw cinnamon
bun and I'm like a possible continuity
error that was gonna say you did
depending on well maybe she lets him go
or he goes on victim II he forgot he was
serving her
I mean what put it past him
that's true so pipe it probably there's
a continuity error this I'm sure they
can like explain it like tap-dance
around it but it's like I'm sure they're
just like yeah we can plan on that yeah
or like this episode maybe came out like
MIT me they had the time C's we're
coming out different like me this was
supposed to come Apple friend yeah
production variant chunk but but no
that's why I hate this episode destroys
the continuity yes my life is ruined
so I'm so sorry well while we have a
play date we can you know exactly you're
not good at this just stop god this is
why I don't do this anymore
cuz you sit there and you try to step
all over what I do you're like look me
up Doug I'm better than you I can do
this so much better
jealous cuz you can